brand in general I would guess point one  percent one percent so why would you  even have one trans woman on that panel  much less two so okay if you're gonna  have one trans woman on that panel cool  I get it throw that in you know how they  say the system is rigged that is rigging  the system there's no need to have two  trans women on a panel representing  women they were they just literally  wanted them there so they could tell me  I have to play sports with dudes like  that's literally what they wanted them  there for [ __ ] and no it's  absolutely [ __ ] because it's like  one it's always the most unathletic  people telling the athletes what we  gotta do and I'm like you want me to go  up against guys women we don't have much  opportunity in women's sports and you're  gonna give the little opportunity we  have to men yeah you're kidding me like  oh no so you must